in this video we're going to be talking
about everything you need to know about
royalty-free music Content ID copyright
strikes and I'm joined by Oscar the CEO
of epidemic sound it's going to be
breaking down some must-know information
as it just pertains to enhancing your
videos with music that's not going to
get you in trouble with YouTube and so
this is kind of a interesting world it's
always changing and there's a lot of
important information that you need to
know so stick around until the end of
this video for all the juicy info smash
like if you're fired up and I want to
welcome Oscar to the stream today Oscar
how's it going
hey Sean thanks for having me
um I'm doing I'm doing great Stockholm
is beautiful even at 9pm
9 p.m you're in Stockholm Sweden I'm in
Las Vegas we are going live lots of
people that are watching on the replay
and I kind of want to Dive Right into
this world because as a YouTube Creator
you step into this world of like I want
to make videos and I would love to just
grab a top 40 song throw it in my video
editing software but all of a sudden now
I've uploaded that to YouTube and I'm
having issues I'm having issues with
copyright now I'm learning terms like
royalty free I there's Content ID
there's all this different stuff so I
kind of want to just lay a foundation
with the definition of terms
um and I'll throw a couple questions at
you define for us what what really is
royalty-free music
so I would argue that royalty-free music
is a term what's the American expression
like the road to hell is paved with good
intentions I think that quote comes to
mind because royalty fee free music was
put together in a galaxy far far away as
Star Wars fan could grab that reference
and it relates back to the notion of
when music was used in a more
traditional linear context as in say
television or something which was
broadcast to many uh there were multiple
rights that needed clearance
um the publishing rights were always
cleared centrally so you didn't really
see them as a Content producer
um however you had to license uh the
master side which is one of the two
copyrights within sort of using music
which we'll talk at length later on and
so the notion was that there is a subset
of Music where the write which is
typically sort of
um in a position that it needs to be
cleared if that's pre-cleared let's go
ahead and use this of a term that makes
sense to people let's call that royalty
free because you don't have to clear
that specific royalty
fast forward to today as we've now
become sort of content creators at scale
ourselves and we distribute some content
everywhere
um it's the case that there are multiple
rights that need to be cleared when you
use a music track at least in the
traditional business in our case not so
much and so the term now royalty free
similar to copyright free get thrown
around quite a bit and the assumption is
that it clears basically everything but
it really doesn't it doesn't clear
everything and I'll pause there because
there are so many nuances to this
yeah so uh I mean it's pretty complex
but what are the list of a few things
for a traditional song I mean there's
like there's the Masters there's the
writers there's the publishing there's a
lot of different things
um and maybe maybe simplifying is it
this is where epidemic sound comes in
because it simplifies the fact of
getting away from kind of a spider web
of legalities that you would face
uploading copy written music to YouTube
correct
correct and so I think that if we spend
a little bit more time on this the way I
would structure it I would say that
there are multiple people involved in
creating great music and as a
consequence over the years what happened
is that there were a bunch of rights to
help protect the commercial interests of
all of these different people who are
involved so there were artists
performing there were composers writing
it there were Studio musicians
performing it they were people
fine-tuning the music producing it and
so as these different names salute to
there were some there were Master rights
there were publishing rights
um the music then got performed and
distributed so there was performance
rights there was then the mechanical
rights because as you created multiple
copies of say CDs or disks or cassettes
or a physical storage unit that too sort
of was deemed something that deserved
copyright and needed some kind of
remuneration so as it varies from
country to Country I try and stay away
from listing exactly what the different
rights are because they can be a bit
different in different territories and
so I the way we see it is we basically
do the inverse and we say that rather
than talking about restriction free
music or copyright free music
um sorry relatively music the term that
we've started to use is restriction free
music because we feel it's more
encompassing and so if anyone were to
ask me what we to do today I would say
that we're the only Global restriction
free music platformer catalog in the
entire world and by default what that
means is that all of the rights that
have been made up today all of the
rights that sort of can be made up in
the future so we've bundle them together
to make sure that as a content creator
it's your Liberty to produce content and
distribute it basically anywhere and
everywhere so our definition is much
more of a positive one as opposed to
trying to list all these different
nuances which tend to have different
names and some different setups and if
from being honest different Dynamics in
different parts of the world
gotcha so ultimately the point of
epidemic sound is to simplify it sounds
like simplifying things to create a
solution so that the creator doesn't
have to be stressed
um and and restriction free is the term
restriction free music so that we can
ultimately uh use great music in our
videos without complexity talk to me a
little bit about the YouTube content ID
system that is the mechanism with which
YouTube
robots and algorithms are listening to
what you say
less probably about what you say but
that probably as well but the music
being used and the visuals being used in
a video to potentially
distribute a copyright strike
or get your video demonetized or even
get your video taken down I'm throwing a
lot at you but what are the consequences
of the potential consequences of using
something copy written
how the content ID system works and then
and then the downstream consequences to
the Creator
yeah so here's how I would phrase this I
would say that
back in the early days when YouTube was
trying to get off the ground
um there wasn't that much available
specific online Centric content maybe
difficult to reflect on that in 2022 but
so back then when things started off
they needed to supercharge the system
and get content up online and so the way
to do that was to reach out to Legacy
content owners and content providers in
some case it was visual content but to a
large degree it was music content so you
reached out to the traditional music
industry and the job was to persuade
them can we persuade you to incorporate
the tracks that you have which some of
them have hundreds of years of years and
some less
um to their name can we put ourselves in
a position so that we can use all of
that music to create content private
option and so try and get this Creator
economy off the ground obviously a
decade before the term existed
and
um the route to getting to that place
and providing security for the
traditional IP asset owners was the
YouTube build built a very sophisticated
system I would still argue Best in Class
as far as like a per platform system
they're now sort of third-party systems
which are great as well but so YouTube
quantity content ID from a technical
perspective like very sophisticated and
increasingly so over the years
so they put together a Content ID system
which catered to a bunch of commercial
terms a bunch of legal terms and the
notion the idea behind that is to
distribute the spoils the revenues the
advertising money fairly and so content
ID got deployed and basically anyone who
was a Content owner who held a piece of
Ip was encouraged by YouTube to do the
following they would say that you know
what here's what we suggest we have
YouTube which is this beautiful system
but we've built a parallel YouTube and
we call it I content ID and anything
that is precious to you anything that
you feel that you own and that you can
prove that it's yours we'd like to
encourage you to upload that to Content
ID because what we'll then do every time
anyone publishes anything online before
we trick push publish and we send that
all across the entire world and we put
ads around it will parallel run that
vis-a-vis Content ID so every time you
publish something shown and you want to
go publish this still happens like 15
years later on and so if you're using a
tracked your earlier reference which is
like a top 40 hit song
odds are and the odds are very very high
that that piece of content will be in
Content ID and the underlying content
owner so it could be the record label
the publisher the pros back to the whole
notion that there are many many
different entities who hold many
different claims many different parts
because copyright is should I say rich
as is a kind way of saying complicated
they all get a ping within the system
saying like hey Sean is now using your
track like what do you want to do
and the IP owner is presented with three
options and they can either go track or
block or monetize
and the downstreams for consequence from
your perspective they're shown is that
if they opt for track basically the
people who control the rights are going
to be able to track all your views all
your usage get the Intel onto what's
trending what's working and in theory
like this has huge commercial value
because if I'm if I'm the manager of an
artist and I'm seeing like holy cow like
this music is doing really well in
Arkansas or in Philadelphia or in Las
Vegas as an example like that gives me a
good inclination of I'm going to be
planning a tour during the Spring like I
have a great idea where I should go
because I can see through IP addresses
where my fans are so hypothetical
example but that's one version that they
get
the second version that they get is
monetize
and so the dynamic at play here was that
YouTube were super smart hands down so
there was this notion that okay so if
Sean steals music let's use that term
and he publishes it the IP owner can as
I said track they can obviously block
which is the most nuclear option right
they can say that nope not on our watch
we don't want you to publish this
because we have great plans for this
track it's destined for different things
and if you use this in your show and
interview this Shady guy Oscar like we
we're not excited about that we'll just
say no
but then they invented the monetized
version which was sheer brilliant
because they said that technically Sean
is this great content creator he's a
ninja he has this super interesting
following will allow him to use our
music but because we can rely on YouTube
and our friends over at content ID we'll
just tell YouTube but yep Sean is using
this music nope doesn't have a license
nope he's not paid the publisher nor the
pro nor the neighboring rights he's
basically not paid anyone but we're okay
with that as long as you put ads on his
content monetize his reach send all of
that money to us thank you very much
and so the system sort of created
optionality because there was choice and
sort of off we went to the races like
what became sort of clearer and clearer
sort of down the line was that hang on
what's the American expression here like
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me so let's say for argument's
sake that you put a hundred hours into
this show like some cutting it adding it
coming up with the idea you've catered
like 75 million subscribers as I know
you haven't like built this huge
following everyone's really excited you
push out the content so the way you
finance that is running ads
but this is where the core cap is right
so you use one track where there's one
person in One subset of all of these
complicated rights that I spoke about so
they call themselves royalty free but as
long as they're not restriction free
there's always the one that got away and
basically they hold the Vita right and
they can say I want all of Sean's
Revenue
and so this started to happen of course
it was a trickle what's the expression
first it was drops and then the Trickle
and then there was a flood wave and
there were like a huge swap of content
creators making content like really
pouring their Heart and souls into it
but if you used music that wasn't
restriction free a hundred percent like
a hundred percent of the revenue ended
up with the music IP owners and suddenly
you you were a pro bono business without
opening in without knowing for it and
your money wasn't going to pro bono it
was going to some record label somewhere
who was laughing all the way to the bank
so that turned out to be like a big
issue and then sort of to make matters
worse
income few bad actors into Content ID
and some of these IPO holders could also
say that so if they wanted to be really
severe under some circumstances they
could say that not only are we going to
block your content but they could issue
copyright strikes so they introducer
system which was basically you use music
that you don't have right to one two or
now I think it's three times you're
strapped with a copyright block they can
ultimately demonetize you start shutting
features off from A View and then worst
case like shut your channel down which
unfortunately is not unheard of
like enter epidemic and I think I'll
pause there but so that was the world
that the people were facing like music
to content is the equivalent of taste to
food
I it's so incredibly important like so
if you don't get the music right it's
it's the difference between being
memorable and being Unforgettable like
food without taste is just nourishment
you're never gonna write home about it
you're not going to tell your friends
about it but food that has an incredible
taste it's next level stuff and the same
is true with music so it's so incredibly
important and there are tons of things
you can DIY you can film yourself you
can edit yourself you can cut yourself
but ultimately when you start to move
towards music and you're like wait a
minute to I use about one track per
minute of content if I make five minute
content five times a week like that's 25
different tracks every single week and
the tracks tell a story this is scary
this is uplifting this is suspense like
this is quirky like there are so many
different nuances you want to catch and
you can't produce that yourself just
simply can't DIY it that's when the star
started to align that somebody
ought to help content creators at scale
somebody want to help unlock people so
they can create basically anything
anywhere with amazing quality and
content but it needs to travel and it
needs to be part of our business I can't
be giving away everything I do because
of one specific right in this case music
doesn't work
this is super valuable and we're going
to do a quick recap and then talk about
of course uh how to power up our videos
with music learn a little bit about the
different offerings of epidemic sound
but if you've been getting value smash
like on the uh this video and I want to
shout out we got Oregon and Wisconsin
and Idaho and Australia and uh Dominica
the nature of the island in the house
Iowa and the house New Jersey good to
see y'all and um we are talking to Oscar
the co-founder and CEO of epidemic sound
we've learned kind of about the history
of royalty-free Music copyright free
music very complex web of record labels
and rights holders
um but epidemic sound has created
restriction free music to simplify that
for Content creators so that you don't
get copyright strikes you don't
ultimately get demonetized or ultimately
have your your channel taken down and
what's interesting Oscar is Art Club
actually brought I'm so afraid of using
music and I mean I don't blame you it's
it's stressful you put so much work into
a video just as you described and what's
been interesting is I've been creating
videos and editing videos now
ever since I mean I was doing it before
YouTube started from my local church in
2003 and four we started a YouTube
channel for my church in 2007 super
early there was 15 minute upload limits
at the time
on video length
um and I remember I would go to I would
look for a lot of Indie artists for this
reason and I would go to SoundCloud or
I'd email artist directly but to your
point what would be interesting was
sometimes even they did not own their
own rights or distribution or something
with change or they would and I don't
blame them later on upload their their
song to Content ID and lo and behold a
video that I'd put my heart and soul
into all of a sudden we get flagged or
we get demonetized and so there
definitely is a massive need for a
solution to this problem and the other
side of the problem is if you go to all
kinds of different websites and actually
look for royalty-free music
it's terrible like it's generally been
an absolute you like okay at least it's
safe but I can't tell a great story here
because the music is so bad this is one
of the reasons why we love epidemic
sound so much so tell us a little bit
and then and by the way today's video is
brought to you of course by epidemic
we've been working with you guys for a
while and uh you can check out a link in
the description to
um we have a one year subscription for
50 off and 30-day trial and all that
kind of stuff with promo code think 50.
so details in the description about that
but tell me about the vision epidemic
sound started in 2009 and not to go a
little bit later here but slight Rabbit
Trail
I'm so inspired because 2009 was a
recession and it's debatable but right
now it would seem or more than same that
we are in a recession Tech layoffs a lot
of interesting things are happening but
it's so inspiring that you guys started
a company I think like Airbnb The Joe
Rogan podcast started in 2009 I'm not
sure if you were aware of that there's
just something powerful about you know
being Innovative being creative and I
really believe that in any economy in
any season there's opportunity so 2009
you have a vision I would say kind of
prophetically ahead of a lot of what was
happening
talk a little bit about epidemic sound
and how you guys solve the problem of of
music for storytellers creators
um and uh the inherent problems with
royalty-free music and low quality music
yeah
so thanks for setting that up
beautifully shown so mentally we're all
now back in 2008 2009 to your point most
definitely there is a recession
um and we're in the middle of it
um around this time I found myself uh
similar to yourself doing something
slightly different I was in TV
production so we were making TV shows we
were making the go with the Dragon
Tattoo all around the world of course we
made the Swedish ones then we made the
American ones and sort of thoroughly
enjoyed doing that and similar to the
question that popped up like we stumbled
upon two problems and so the first
problem was that
um it was incredibly intimidating and
frustrating and difficult as a
Storyteller to use music to bring our
stories to life like
I kid you not to we definitely saw it as
music to content is the equivalent of
taste of food so it's instrumental to
really create something compelling but
we were terrified because we knew
without a shadow of a doubt that finding
music was difficult licensing it paying
for it understanding who and what
filling out music cue sheets negotiating
in absurd long periods of time we found
ourselves using less music because we
were basically afraid to make a mistake
and we took some issue with that uh I
think the realization was that this is
just wrong like adding music to content
isn't that supposed to be the most fun
part when your content pops it speaks
you you get goosebumps and you feel like
wow this is great stuff we were feeling
the exact opposite like I don't want to
do this like this so somebody else is
there an intern can somebody else do
this because I'm I'm afraid of what the
consequences might be that was how the
industry was thinking and this was the
first problem like that's wrong it ought
to be fun to add content if you're a
Storyteller and it's a music content fit
together
now the flip side of that because we
were five co-founders at epidemic was
that three of the founders were also
music creators and they were incredibly
talented at creating music I think
Sweden is this tiny weird little country
10 million people we speak ridiculous
language it's by the North Pole I we're
mediocre at many things but we're really
good at music and we're really good at
engineering right so we knew that this
is something that we excel at
but the music industry was struggling
like music creators they weren't able to
support themselves it was difficult so
people had like a second job and a third
job and they'd work at Walmart in the
post office like you couldn't sustain
yourself as a music creator
um because the business was basically
vinyl some people had massive hits but
there was nothing in between so the
system didn't work it was great in
theory it was supposed to be royalty and
and and
um like the notion of we laughed
Together We Cried together
but in practice it didn't work it wasn't
transparent it wasn't run by technology
and there were so many different chefs
in the kitchen like everyone felt
entitled so there were record labels and
Publishers and pros and neighboring
rights and somewhere along that sort of
big fight people lost track and lost
sight of the music creators so they were
always the ultimate losers in this
equation
and we looked at that we said like huh
that's just wrong as well what if there
was a music industry which was centered
around creativity around music creators
what if we could see a world where music
creators were the ultimate winners in
the music industry wouldn't that be cool
and the dawn on us like storytellers are
looking for
music to bring their content to life and
music creators are looking for stories
to connect them with audiences and
distribution like there ought to be
something happening here right
but the way the lay of the land that
wasn't materializing and then I think
for us it all came together in like this
basically this realization we came to
understand that okay
at some point I have three kids Sean so
at some point I think that like 20 years
from now I'm gonna be walking down
Stockholm with one of my grandkids and
she's gonna look at me and like in a
moment of sincerity she can go grandad
let's be honest for a while I'm like
okay and she's gonna say that like your
generation you almost screwed everything
up right so I'm not taking care of the
planet but thankfully you you fixed that
in the last minute so you're enduring
Legacy like what your generation is
known for hands down
it's the you you invented the Internet
like that's the coolest thing your
generation did like it's amazing
and like chuckle it's a similar smile on
my face do you do Sean and I'm like okay
what do you mean she's like but it's
amazing right because we use the
internet to do everything like shop Bank
educate sort of talk to our friends our
family express ourselves creativity like
the Internet it's the core of everything
we do and you invented that how cool is
that
high five I go into a candy store we buy
some candy heading down the street again
and then she's gonna pause and she's
gonna look at me see when we go but
grandad
if that was your generation's defining
moment if that's what put you on the map
if that's your Woodstock moment as a
generation can you remind me how did you
contribute
what was your role in that
did you help out did you throw your hat
in the ring did you help build what
ultimately is your legacy
and for us that epidemic sort of
it was clear from day one and this is
approaching 14 years ago that wouldn't
it be incredibly cool if we could have
this fictitious discussion in the future
and we get to lean in and with a smile
on our face we get to say you know what
we actually did see what was going on we
racked our brains and the most profound
thing the best thing we could come up
with was that it would be amazing if we
could lean in and get to say that yeah
we understood what was happening and we
decided let's see if we can soundtrack
the internet what if we could be the
company that unlocks and democratizes
creativity brings our species most
prolific trait the art and storytelling
which started around fires what if we
could help supercharge that and just
unleash creativity and music Across the
entire internet what if we helped build
this incredibly Rich Mosaic which is
basically all stories across all
platforms just make it really compelling
so that the internet is this Rich
repository of basically the best of
humanity wouldn't that be amazing
so that's what we set out to do all
those years ago and we said it's a way
of getting there is that the old
industry is so complicated it's built on
misunderstanding it's built to be
difficult and we can't join them we need
to just rethink everything so we re
thought how we can compensate music
creators by paying them up front then
redesigning royalties paying that out
without going through five ten different
middlemen we then made it super simple
for all the content creators out there
saying that it doesn't matter if you use
Content ID or YouTube or other platforms
like nobody wants to have a PhD in
copyright you don't need to understand
like publishing law Master rights sync
Mechanicals because they are all going
to change and they all have like let's
just give people a free pass saying that
you don't need that like we're going to
take something very complicated and make
it super simple we're epidemic we're
going to coin a new term because
restriction free so that's where we need
to go royalty free is misleading
copyright free is misleading but
restriction free you can't go wrong it's
a One-Stop shop you pay a fixed monthly
fee it's small if you're small it's big
if you're on Netflix and so if we cater
it to the size and the ambition of what
your business is and then sort of that's
it we'll stop give us your YouTube
channel we're white listed in perpetuity
everything just works and you can create
whatever you want however you want how
often how little how much and we
guarantee that there will be no problems
that was the initial idea that was
something which up here for ourselves
was super complicated but as soon as we
tried to explain to people and speak in
other people's behalf like this is the
music industry and this is this and this
is that I it just made a way too
complicate and back to a point like we
want to be super duper simple like
exceptional value exceptionally simple
let's go
I love it I mean it's a compelling
vision and
um I also as a you know I have a
background being a DJ in high school I
actually spun vinyl records hip-hop and
EDM and grew up in Seattle so I grew up
in grunge and cool uh Nirvana and this
whole that whole scene as a snowboard
and skateboarder too you you are you're
in a lot of underground music and all
kinds of stuff so I developed an ear
also as a video editor and that's one of
the reasons why I love epidemic is
because of the quality of the artists
and the music and the sounds that you
provide
um it is incredibly it's a powerful
resource because it matters and I like
your analogy towards flavor to food as
music to our YouTube videos
um I want to hear a little bit about
specifically we have some there's
actually many people that use epidemic
are watching right now maybe people
watching the replay and by the way if
you want to try it out right now you can
use the promo code think50 you can get
50 off of a year-long subscription and
get a free trial just so you can check
it out as well
um you've got different levels as you
mentioned and I think one of the
compelling things is you can meet people
at a personal level where they can use
the content across social media YouTube
Facebook Instagram Tick Tock twitch
but if you go to a commercial level you
also can you have coverage for your
client or business so if you're doing
video production is that saying that you
get rights ultimately to be able to use
those songs in a wedding video that you
deliver
um as well as even digital ads is also
on that I see on the commercial plan for
some of us we run Facebook ads we run
ads across platforms
um and so break that down a little bit
as far as your your products meeting
people at a personal level a commercial
level and the differences
yeah so um I think that maybe
25 years ago two people sat in a room
like similar to your to you Sean and
myself maybe and they were discussing
like
um websites like having a a homepage and
one of the people so we took took the
position saying that you know what I bet
that in 20 years from now every single
company on the planet is going to have a
website like hands down everyone
and I'm going to be the person on the
other end like in this example Sean I'm
gonna what really so why what are they
going to put on that who's going to run
it it makes no sense like what do you
mean are they going to go online and do
what no maybe a few Fortune 500
companies in the US perhaps like with
huge organizations but everyone makes no
sense
like Fast Forward 20 years
um and I think it's quite obvious that
not only did every single company on the
planet Earth decide to have a website
every single human on the planet Earth
has not one but multiple like a tick
tock LinkedIn Facebook YouTube twitch
Pinterest like you name it so it's just
exploded right and so it took longer but
the change was much more profound
now why do I bring this up well I bring
this up because we had the exact same
vision for lack of a better word like
all these years ago we said that sort of
okay
so
2008-2009 the internet is very
tech-centric like there's text
everywhere it's quite boring from honest
and then sort of we started to see a few
pictures pop up like pre-instagram
obviously but we felt as though okay so
the internet is probably going to evolve
from text to picture
and then we became really convinced like
well in advance like over time we think
that the entire internet is going to be
video Centric what's the expression like
a picture says more than a thousand
words where the video says more than a
thousand pictures we were so convinced
because it's such a compelling way for
us humans to interact through video
because you can capture information but
you can also capture emotion it's just
like a superior way for us humans to
interact so we knew without a shadow of
that that all of the internet is going
to be around
um around video and initially people
thought that the opportunity is maybe a
few production companies like there are
a few thousand media companies out there
but we were adamant we said no like
that's not going to be the case it's
going to be the case so like everyone is
going to use video to communicate you're
going to use video if you want to if you
have a nail salon and you do some great
Halloween nails you're going to want to
reach people and tell them about that
but your employees the people you work
with the people you employ you
Regulators your customers like you're
going to want to use video when you
onboard new people to teach them about
your service or how you edit something
or how you
um sort of do color grading or something
like that video is going to supercharge
all forms of communication
and again we looked at all of this and
we said like wow there's going to be a
lot of video out there
let's make it super simple let's make
sure that we can accommodate for all of
that so let's not go into huge amounts
of detail but let's assume that some
people will have a personal usage
um perspective and so they will want to
use this for Content that they create by
themselves ad hoc it's something they
run so
um either by the side it's not their
main line of business
um though they run it through sort of
ads on YouTube and whatnot let's create
something what resonates like personal
plan perfect let's keep it simple that's
what you get to do
and then we took a second step like
what's the alternative well so that's a
commercial plan you do this as your
full-time gig you're a freelancer you
work for other people exactly so use the
commercial plan to do the comment which
just popped up and we allow for
basically all kinds of commercial usage
and so just make it super duper simple
so we created these two specific plans
and then towards as we started to grow
and there was more and more traction to
your point like music-wise as well we
started small humble beginnings but as
the the vision grew the business grew
the footprint grew now we have huge
amounts of Music which we produce every
single day and we release it to
consecutively every single week every
single month of sort of constant updates
hundreds and hundreds of tracks from
thousands of artists all around the
world
so much so that we now have an
Enterprise offering as well with some of
the most prolific and largest Brands and
Storyteller organizations on the planet
use our offering as well but we still
opted to keep it super simple as a
personal plan a commercial plan or you
can reach out directly and become an
Enterprise customer
that's how that's our vision of keeping
it simple like super relevant but again
super simple
I love it it makes total sense and you
know there's actually a couple tips I
wanted to share of of some of the stuff
that we use when it comes to epidemic
first of all we have a couple albums out
so if you're already a user you can
check out think media sounds uh
different songs that I picked out I
built out this playlist and then Omar
did one called think Essentials
um volume one excited to be drop in
volume 2 in the future and so if you
want to see just again you could go here
and of course listen through this music
as well get a feel for it but if you're
an if you have a membership you can use
these songs in your content creation one
of my other favorite things to do though
is to check out the epidemic sound
um Spotify playlist because you could
take the playlist of songs you love I
like to do this when I'm driving or I'm
on a road trip and then I heart or save
these songs
um as I'm listening and then when I get
home to do an edit I'm ultimately able
to have already kind of pre-curated
songs that resonated with me so I have
kind of a Personal Collection any video
editor knows any content creator knows
that if you're in the middle of an edit
and you start going to look for music it
could be a fun experience but it also
can be a one two three four five six day
long experience trying to find the right
song so I have found that in my margin
Time by going to Spotify listening
through some of those uh playlists there
while I'm taking a shower or something
I'll be like oh that song slaps that's a
great song and then I just kind of save
that so I'm always building up kind of a
repository
of incredible songs that resonate with
me my style
um and then I'm ready to use those later
and so a couple tips and you know
today's video is brought to you by
epidemic uh you can get a one year
subscription and you can get 50 off of a
one year that doesn't apply to the
monthly plan I believe at just the year
long
um but you can also start off with a
50-day trial when you sign up for that
just make sure you use the promo code
think50 and details about that is in the
description down below we've been
actually working with epidemic now for a
couple years I believe
um and happily so of course it is a kind
of brand sponsorship relationship but we
only recommend Brands and products that
we personally love and use and I would
think I think that we have good taste I
think media Omar and Nolan and Kyle and
Heather and myself we're all music Geeks
and so we it's not a it's a no-brainer
for us for this collaboration just
because of how excellent your product is
your interface the user experience but I
think most importantly is the curation
of the music as well as sound effects
that you guys pull together and I'm
curious what is the Cadence for
uploading new content I think it's 35
000 songs I mean that's what the website
says now so there's already a deep well
of really great music but how often are
you guys adding more sound effects and
music to the library
so let me get back to that in just a
second but before we do I just want to
tie back to the tips that you were
sharing Sean I think they're great I'd
just love to add two tips to that list
so the first one would be encouraging
everyone listening
um we released our app earlier this year
and the use case that you describe in
terms of being in a road trip obviously
not driving sitting next to the person
driving listening or sort of running the
DJ which I assume is going to be you uh
Sean
um using the epidemic app while you're
out and about listening finding tracks
favoriting them so that's a great way of
using the service as well so moving from
one platform to many to make it so much
much easier and the second one is that
we have something which we call Air
which we're incredibly excited about so
on the website sort of the functionality
is typically if you go into a track and
you listen to it and you click the track
on the right hand side there's this
function called ear and it's powered by
Ai and what it is is basically if you
find a track that you like you can
identify the the segment of that track
which you find compelling right and then
we run AI on that and we look at the
entire catalog all of our 35
000 tracks are 90 000 sound effects and
we play back exactly that segment that
build that drop that tone that voice
that word and we'll show you all the
things in the library which are similar
to that thing so it's like a super cool
way to your point like you find
something you like it's it's like
finding similar times 10. so it's like
exactly there you go exactly so it's a
powerful tool and this is what it looks
like
so so then you've got uh I'm doing it
here right now and his ear gonna show up
down here
exactly
okay so now it's similar from zero to
250 or from 50 to uh 104. these other
let's see how it changes right yeah you
see how it changes
that's that's that's clean that's
amazing so you could find
um similar
beats per minute you're building a field
a build a drop like something that
you're looking for you find the part you
use the way from so it captures that for
you and then you can just play around
with it it's the heads up it's a rabbit
hole because you can get completely
sucked in because you're like this is
good oh this is even better oh wait this
is even better
and then and then use the new ear
feature and and that's amazing we didn't
really cover the basics which without
any of the aforementioned tips simply
um using your discover feature and and
searching related to Dreamy laid-back
beats per minute different types of
music lots of curated albums curated
playlists
um it is a rabbit hole for sure but you
do make it
very user friendly to find high quality
music
um that is the right mood energy Vibe
for whatever story uh people
um want to tell so
um you know so back to the question
um what kind of what how do you work
with artists and and and new music
that's coming out and what's sort of
like the Cadence of of rolling out new
new music
so to give you a sense of our footprint
we're somewhere like every single day I
think on YouTube alone our music gets
played 1.7 1.8 billion times right so
we're a huge provider across like
millions of channels
and that's a huge privilege but there's
also a huge responsibility
fortunately for us because we're into
music storytelling and also we're
Engineers like all of that music it
leaves a footprint so we have a sense of
what the internet sounds like what's
working on YouTube and so we aggregate
data and we can see what are people
playing what are they downloading what
are they looking for what's being used
on YouTube what are you and the people
that are watching this what are the
comments that they're getting
um what are the things that people are
vibing with what's the music that's
striking a chord and we accumulate all
of this information and it informs us
and it tells us that wow this is doing
really well or this part of our catalog
is being used very heavily or these are
terms that people are searching for
where we're coming up short or this is
stuff that's doing really well across
YouTube and it's traveling to Spotify
and it's ending up on these playlists
and it's getting billions of streams and
lots of views so we take all of that
together and that informs us and it
gives us a data set to really help sort
of supercharge the music that we then
Commission because we then look at the
thousands of Music creators that we work
with and based on the signal that we're
getting our own
um conceptions and Desires in terms of
how we'd like to expand the catalog the
library what we think that people are
interested in what we see that are
looking for this is how we put our
commissions out there and so any given
month there are hundreds and hundreds of
tracks which are being produced put up
there and put into the catalog so this
is together with the current 35 000
track this is together with the 90 000
sound effects and so there's always an
ongoing editing so we're not of the
opinion that more is more for the sake
of volume I when it comes to music and
sound effects we argue seven days a week
it's much important that it's relevant
that it's to the point that you quickly
get to this is what I'm trying to do
this is what I want to accomplish with
combining this piece of content with
this piece of music this is what I want
to do and so the combination for us so
like constantly refreshing our catalog
there's new stuff coming in there every
single month every single week
um layer on top of that which we've not
spoken about either which is the whole
notion of stems right so every single
track you can break out the vocals or
the instruments or the drums so we make
a track more versatile like if if like
this was one of my major pain points
when we came from TV production over
those years ago well tip user case would
be you found a great track unfortunately
there's somebody singing in the track
where there's a super annoying trombone
or there's some instrument that just
doesn't sit well with you and in the
video you're talking or someone else is
talking on this chapter there's a
message right so the track the beat you
love can't use it because there's song
in it so you find a small sub segment of
that song you copy that you Loop it you
try and recreate the track and we said
so that's a nightmare like that's tens
of hours of editing Let's Just Produce
everything from day one in separate
stems so you can listen to the entire
track and then you can go you know what
first five seconds let's take out the
singing when we're done talking let's
add the singing let's take out the drums
let's put the drums back in let's pull
out the guitar and so we make sure that
we make the tracks much more versatile
right exactly here we go
so this is when you download so I think
that if you go one step back Sean so if
you just play the regular track so yeah
go cancel so you you press play for play
this one
yeah and then if you go to the right you
see like there we go Arrow up there
that's the one and so this is where you
can play the full mix the melody in
isolation the instrument in isolation
the drums night and you can play around
you can see exactly in terms of oh I
like this oh I don't like this and if
this gets the job done you downloads of
all of these different stamps and then
we believe that it's better that you get
to choose the editing station so if
you're a cap cut or adobe or whatever is
of
whatever you want to use you make sure
that you download all the different
stamps and then you can play around with
it as much or as little as you like pull
it into your timeline adapt it to change
it around a bit like that's what really
being a Creator is about if you ask us
and so if you if you if you think this
is too complicated if you're a personal
plan user you have a full mix we'll take
care of it we give you suggestions but
if you want to play around with these if
you really want to make it memorable
unique and this is like this is not a
piece of content this is the piece of
content well then of course you're going
to want to layer in stems and sound
effects and just make it really pop
no that's absolutely brilliant and I do
love that Simplicity of course you've
got uh just simply separating out the
the track if there is lyrics to start
with and vocals to maybe slap on that
intro there's that powerful line Nolan's
done a couple of our growth video kind
of hip-hop based kind of motivational
rap versus those have been powerful but
then you maybe want that to drop out so
having the instrumental version so that
now when there's talking you're not
fighting over those lyrics but you just
took it to a whole other level if you go
to the stems level you just have an
accordion of how complex you want to get
but also how nuanced do you want to get
and I love the fact that for the
Savvy editor not only could you
potentially maybe drop the whole song
maybe there's a point where you want to
hit the mood and just do the Baseline
maybe come back to that whole song and
then of course for dynamic editors
starting to layer in sound effects and
whatnot I mean the creativity
opportunities are endless but just as
important and this is big for I think
our community also the ease of use and
simplicity opportunities are endless as
well because of course for Content
creators it's about speed of creation a
lot of times not every video are we
editing hours and hours and hours not
every video is necessarily a masterpiece
in some cases it's just getting out
consistent content and there's such a
spectrum of what we create as content
creators here on YouTube as video
editors and so uh that's beautiful no
and and the feature set the way that
epidemic continues to evolve is very
impressive I mean it's it's an
incredible platform and um it's really
cool to see all this stuff
you know I think that however I mean at
the end of the day our company ethos is
it's super clear I it's such a privilege
to get to work with yourself Sean to
everyone listening like the idea the
notion that we get to sit in Stockholm
outskirts of Europe and so from here
work with thousands of talented music
creators play a tiny part in millions of
storytellers like yourselves and just
help hopefully tell stories to hopefully
help people evolve hopefully help people
get inspired we're incredibly grateful
for that opportunity like anytime we get
feedback from anyone it's the biggest
Gifts of possible we love reacting to
that we love changing we have as a
commitment like so the only thing we can
promise is that we're never going to be
done we're like constantly trying to
improve constantly trying to update our
way of thinking our way of facilitating
these stories because ultimately I think
that 20 years from now is when we can
look back and see like did we do a good
job did we help make the internet
beautiful did we help craft
fantastic stories that put a smile on
her face and make us proud as a
generation of like we built the internet
this is all on you the listeners and
you're all amazing
that's the goal
Oscar man I love the vision and uh I I
can tell as a true music lover and
artist yourself it's just incredible to
see what y'all have built and continue
to build to serve the Creator economy
um if you're just joining or watching
this video this video is brought to you
by epidemic sound and I know uh some of
you have been mentioning you're having
trouble with the code that should work
in the next 30 minutes if not it'll work
today for sure we're on that right now
but if you want to grab a one-year
subscription uh we've been using
epidemic before ever having a brand deal
before working uh with you guys it was
something we invested in ourselves
um because we absolutely believe in it
and again it's simple it solves the
problem great music for your videos with
a lot of creative flexibility as well as
sound effects so if you want to get a
one-year subscription 50 off and a
30-day trial you could do that at
epidemicsound.com there's also a link in
the description below but make sure to
use the promo code think50 that is the
promo code think 50 Oscar I want to
thank you so much for uh joining us
today really appreciate you and the
entire team
um thank you for jumping on at 9 00 p.m
Sweden time uh and uh and so grateful
for you and uh thank you think media
podcast smash like if you got value if
you're just joining check out the replay
there's a lot of nuggets of wisdom in
terms of enhancing your videos and
understanding music for YouTube Content
ID copyright strikes all that kind of
stuff you want to stay safe if you want
to check out epidemic and other things
as well as our albums Omar's album the
album that I curated those are in the
description down below and then click or
tap the screen to check out another
episode of the think media podcast uh
you can listen to the most recent
episode and I know that'll help you grow
your YouTube channel faster and reach
your goals my name is Sean Cannell
rhymes with YouTube channel excited to
talk to y'all soon love sending a
massive love and respect peace out y'all